Pele coming home for the very last time
the football ground where he made his
name as a 16 year old
the small Villa belmiral Stadium
returned the Santos team into a global
force and himself into oh hey the king
a mark of his Royal status the elite
military unit which usually guards the
president assigned to watch over his
coffin and then the mourners came
thousands filing past to pay their last
respects
they have been omnipresent in Brazil for
so long it was hard for some to
comprehend that he was gone
by the time I passed his coffin I felt
like crying because I knew I know that
this is the last time
it's hard to overstate the importance of
pelay to a country in which the
government once declared him legally a
National Treasure his was the dream
rising from a childhood shining shoes to
being the embodiment of Brazil's hope
and joy at a time darkened by a military
dictatorship
abroad too he was fated and idolized as
someone who made the difficult look easy
and football fun
the first picture I had on the wall in
my bedroom was Pele and it was the
representation and the inspiration of
the best the most beautiful you have in
football so for me it was always my idol
from from very very early age
outside of the stadium the queue to file
past the coffin sniped back on itself
again and again
this year was celebratory not sad after
all Pele was 82 and had struggled with
cancer for a long time
at the lunch and etches local bars
around the ground everyone seemed to
have a story about how they'd seen him
or met him Audrey Chavez told us she was
his nutritionist in his final year
once a month I take his measurements
what he would eat if he was well what a
real honor right I could have never
imagined it like so many here even
though his last game was 45 years ago
the videos of many of its exploits
grainy the stories and the memories have
been passed on young as well as old
turning out to say goodbye
now in the Villa belmiral Stadium The
Last Sunset that its most famous son is
going to see in this place people are
still filing past his coffin to pay
their last respects current Santos
players arrived as Twilight film a
silent question echoing into the dusk as
they left
is there another Pele out there
will there ever be
John Holman Al Jazeera Santos